[MUSIC PLAYING]
JASON ANDREAS: Today, we
welcome Chef Brendon Edward's
of Detroit's Corktown
hot spot, Gold Cash Gold.
Has anyone been?
Show of hands?
AUDIENCE: Woo!
JASON ANDREAS: Most of us.
All right.
Well let's get the other
hands up after this.
Prior to Gold Cash Gold, Chef
Edwards created the original
menu at [INAUDIBLE] Standby--
Hands?
Anyone?
A few?
OK-- when it opened
in 2015 and spent time
at the who's who of Detroit's
restaurants, Forest Grill,
Roast, Katoi, and [INAUDIBLE].
His progressive American
style combines experience
working in Michelin
star restaurants
in Chicago with his time
abroad in Mexico and Japan.
And we'll hear a little
bit more about that
throughout the conversation.
So please welcome to Google
Detroit, Chef Brendon Edwards.
[APPLAUSE]
BRENDON EDWARDS:
So yeah, I'm not
used to normally talking
in front of people.
And it's been probably
since high school,
other than going
to tables and being
in a more intimate setting.
But as I've been
introduced, I'm a chef.
I cook on a daily basis.
I'm in a kitchen.
I've been doing it
for about 18 years.
And I'm just going to
keep my notes closer.
[LAUGHTER]
But yeah, mostly,
as Jason mentioned,
I've been in the Detroit area.
I have, kind of,
been a little bit
of a vagabond moving my
way in and out of the city
as I saw fit.
Not to say that it
wasn't tight sometimes.
You know, I saved up a bunch
of money, moved to Japan,
and then worked there
at a Michelin starred
restaurant for three months,
pretty much, straight.
I worked from 7:30
in the morning
till midnight seven days a week.
So did things like that.
I also spent some
time in Mexico.
I ended up living with a
family that owned a restaurant.
So therefore, I kind of
worked in the restaurant, too.
And then, I've
spent a lot of time
doing what we call in
our industry a stage.
You guys would probably
know it more as,
like, an unpaid internship.
And I've done that
in restaurants
in LA, and Chicago,
and a few other places.
But it's kind of one of
those things that ends up
being a fun and interesting
perspective on how
to approach dining.
All that being said, I've
worked a lot of long hours.
I've spent a lot
of time not getting
paid very much and a lot of
other fairly negative things
that most people
would look at you
and go, why did you
choose to do this?
And a lot of people will say,
oh, it's probably your passion.
You probably love to cook.
And one of the more
interesting things
is that even though I work
holidays, weekends, and I
generally, kind of, cancel
myself out of social events,
I don't love to cook, which
is probably the oddest thing
that most chefs would ever say.
JASON ANDREAS: We haven't heard
that yet out of all the chefs
there have been.
[LAUGHING]
BRENDON EDWARDS: Yeah.
JASON ANDREAS: So that's
certainly a first so far.
BRENDON EDWARDS: All right.
So I've always been
interested in cooking, though.
I think it's a very
interesting way
to interject yourself
into people's lives
without actually being
a full on part of it.
Being in a serious relationship
or family or whatnot.
And I always thought of it
as something interesting.
Going through culinary school,
we took a food history class.
And one of the quotes
that set with me
was that the onset of cooking
was the onset of civilization.
That's what, kind of, birthed
us all sitting around together
chatting and creating this
time around a warm fire
with something cooking and
nourish our brains while we
ended up evolving more.
And that's where I really
love is the fact that we all
get together, and we
are hosts and guests
on a regular basis in our
homes, in restaurants,
and [INAUDIBLE] like this.
You guys are my
host, and I'm a guest
trying to tell you about,
I guess, my perspective
on the world.
JASON ANDREAS: That's one of
the big reasons, too, at Google.
I know we didn't
look at the cafe yet.
But in all of our large
Google offices, we these open,
collaborative cafes spaces.
And it's not just to
give us free food, which
is a very nice benefit, but it's
more about the social aspect.
Like, you know, let's
have meetings there.
Let's get together.
Let's host, interact--
BRENDON EDWARDS: Yeah.
JASON ANDREAS:
--conversate around food.
And food is, kind of,
what brings us together.
But that's not the key
aspect of it, necessarily.
So it sounds very similar to
the philosophy we take here.
BRENDON EDWARDS: Yeah.
And I think that's
what's, kind of, drawn me.
I wanted to tell you a
little bit about my times
and some of the fun
experiences I've
had being a host and a guest.
As I said, I went to Mexico.
I was going to actually
go to the Culinary
Institute of America
in New York, which
is one of the finest
culinary schools in the US.
And I went out and visited
there in August of 2001.
Got to see the World Trade
Centers right before 9/11,
which was really interesting.
Immediately after accepting or
getting my acceptance letter,
I bought a plane ticket
to live in Mexico.
So I've always been
that person that always
did my own thing, despite
my dad didn't really
think that was a great idea.
And that's where it continued.
I thought that maybe this
was a sign this was something
that I shouldn't be doing?
I need to go find my own path.
So I went down there and
found a nonprofit agency.
I ending up working
at a Montessori school
with preschool kids.
It is great.
It probably helped
me with my patience.
I'm not a normal
chef in the kitchen
anymore the way you might
see it on TV with Gordon
Ramsay and all that jazz.
A lot of my cooks have seen
me as more of a zen person.
Like, they don't see me
lose me temper very often,
not to say that I
haven't possibly
thrown some things in my life.
But it helped, and it was an
interesting part of my path.
The culture there
though was interesting
because I started to
actually observe cultures
and how I was received
as a host, how
I was acting as a guest.
I got to travel a little
bit and actually got
to go into houses where
they offered me things
that, as an outsider,
you're told don't eat that.
Don't drink that.
But it feels really odd to not
because they're being so kind.
I mean, like, we eat meat
once every two months.
So we slaughtered
the pig for you.
And we're serving
it with lettuce.
You're not supposed
to eat lettuce.
So obviously, you eat less
and get full a little quicker.
But it's an
interesting perspective
to have that, as a guest, I'm
trying to end up accommodating
my host just as my host
is probably even trying
to accommodate me.
The more interesting
point of view
was after I got
back from Mexico,
I ended up going
through culinary school.
And I decided I
loved hospitality.
I love serving people.
I loved experiencing
that moment of realizing
that you're a part of someone's
life, whether they know it
or not.
Like, they probably
don't know my name.
But I've met many people
that I've cooked for.
But they don't even know
that I cooked for them.
They just said, yeah, I went to
Longman & Eagle and ate brunch,
and it was great.
I was cooking that day.
I know I was because I was
there almost every day.
But their perspective in saying
like, oh, I had a great time
kept me going.
So after I moved
back from Japan,
I went through culinary
school, and that
was going to be my passion.
I was going to commit.
I was going to do it.
I was going to become a
really, really good cook.
And then, I was going to become
the best host I could be.
And I ended up, going
through culinary school,
I worked for Brian Poulsen.
Opened up Forest Grill, which
is right around the corner
from here.
I was the first AM
sous chef there.
I worked a lot.
I loved it.
Every time I saw a
chef jot down a note,
I took notes on his notes.
And I went home and I
researched so I could figure out
how to make polenta because I
had never made polenta before.
So I wanted to know everything.
And this was my way of trying
to be the best host I can.
And I realized I started--
in looking back on
my time and spending
time with the culture of
Mexico and the people there--
I realized I was starting to
become part of the culture
here.
But I was still more
interested in making sure
that I could see not only the
culture here but that culture
elsewhere, and how to actually
pull that into our culture
because, as
Americans, we've kind
of adopted lots of cultures.
And those cultures have
become intrinsically us.
People from all
over the world, we
come here and
bring our cuisines,
and we bring everything we are.
And then, we adapt it with
all the people we're around.
Italian food, if
you go to Italy,
isn't the same here
as it is in Italy.
I think if anyone has been to
Italy, you'll realize that.
So I decided I'd go as far
away from French cuisine
and American everything
I possibly could.
So I thought about how
isolated Japan was.
So I traveled to Japan.
And I went there.
I studied everyday, Japanese,
for six months before I left.
I did five days a week.
I did four hours a day.
I bought Rosetta Stone.
I bought Japanese for Dummies.
All those things
because I didn't
want to seem like I
was stupid the moment
I walked in the door.
That being said, I walked
up to this Michelin two
starred restaurant.
It's currently
Michelin three starred.
A place called Kichisen
with Chef Yoshimi Tanigawa.
And he came down
befitting of what
you can imagine Japanese men--
well you can imagine Japan.
He came down wearing a
monochromatic yellow jumpsuit
at 8 o'clock in the morning,
happy, and ready to go.
I think he was like
56 or 57 at the time
and had more energy than
any person I can imagine
at 8 o'clock in the
morning, especially
after I realized the hours
that he was putting in.
And immediately-- I had
a translator there--
he started talking
to me because he
knew I was studying Japanese.
And I could tell he was
talking a little slower
and things like that.
I didn't understand a single
word he said until he said,
you understand that?
I felt horrible.
I studied the wrong language.
I don't know what happened.
But my time with him was
also really interesting
because it's completely devoid
of a lot of the cultural norms
that we have and the
cultural norms that I
had studied of Western culture.
He does a style
cooking called keisuke,
which is paired with
their tea ceremony, which
I got to study it with a
bunch of 40-year-old women
that giggled like
middle school girls
the entire time, every
Wednesday for three hours.
That being said, I got to
sit on my knees for about two
of those hours.
And then, they asked me to
gracefully get up all the time.
That doesn't work, even
in a 27-year-olds body.
But I spent some time with
him, and it was really
amazing what he was as a host.
I kind of called myself
a guy [INAUDIBLE]
because he would bring me
everywhere he would go.
He loved having me there and
wanted to show me everything.
I worked for free.
That being said, I
lived in a dormitory
with a few other
apprentices on a bunk bed.
My top bunk was the kitchen.
So it was like a rice cooker
and an induction burner.
That was about it.
But he would bring me
everywhere he'd go.
There's one of my
favorite times,
which I didn't even
understand what was happening,
is he would tell me
to go get dressed up.
He told me to put
on a tuxedo, which
I took as I didn't
bring a tuxedo,
so I'm going to wear a button up
shirt, and a belt, and slacks,
and the nicest shoes I have.
And he did this every
time we went out.
And so he told me to go get
dressed up in my tuxedo.
And I ran across to the
dormitory, came back,
and he was dressed up.
And he really loved--
what's his name?
The designer that has all
the tattoo print on it.
Christian?
JASON ANDREAS: Audigier?
BRENDON EDWARDS: No.
A different one.
AUDIENCE: Ed Hardy?
BRENDON EDWARDS: Ed Hardy.
[LAUGHING]
Christian is the-- yeah, sorry.
So Ed Hardy.
He loved Ed Hardy.
And he wore all Ed Hardy.
And we talked about it on
that drive that I remember.
He told me about how
the hat he was wearing
was Ed Hardy and shoes.
JASON ANDREAS:
What year was this?
The early 2000s?
BRENDON EDWARDS: This was 2010.
JASON ANDREAS: Oh.
BRENDON EDWARDS: Yep.
JASON ANDREAS: So a little bit
late for the Ed Hardy trend,
but that's OK.
BRENDON EDWARDS: Yeah.
But head to toe, all the
way down to his underwear,
which he did point out that he
was wearing Ed Hardy underwear.
And we're driving
through, and we're
talking about the little
amount that we can talk.
And then, we stop.
And he pulls and gets
into a parking spot.
And I had my
Nintendo DS with me.
And just in case I
needed to translate,
there's was a program on
there that I can actually
write Kanji or
Japanese characters,
and it would translate it
into what I need to know.
And as he's getting out, I
opened the door to get out.
And he goes no, no, no.
Chotto matte.
I go, all right.
That means wait.
And then, I close the door.
And I see him get out.
And he goes into this place.
I don't know what he's doing.
Then I realize he's
getting a haircut.
And I'm just waiting in the car.
[LAUGHTER]
All right.
That's fine.
Then, he gets back in the car.
And we continue
our conversation.
Start driving around again.
And I thought maybe we're
going to the market.
Maybe he's going to
show me something.
Maybe he was going to
take me out for lunch.
I'm not sure.
And then, we just pull
back up to the restaurant.
And he says, go get dressed.
Be ready for work.
It.
He took me on a car ride.
I was like, I feel like a pet.
This is amazing.
[LAUGHTER]
But we had lots of fun
adventures like that.
He took me on a run once
just to go see something.
I got to meet the yakuza
that came up to his door
with a Buddhist monk that
drove the yakuza around.
But he always kept
me by his side
because he always
loved hosting me.
And me, as a guest, I tried
my best to be a good guest.
Of which turns into this
story, which is on our run
one day where he told me to
get dressed up in a tuxedo,
and then he was in a, once
again, monochromatic jumpsuit,
and we went on a run.
And it was, like,
a four mile run.
And I was running
in dress shoes.
[LAUGHTER]
And as we were
running, he stopped,
and he gave me a camera.
And he says, run up there.
Take a photo of me.
I said, all right.
So I ran up ahead
of him a little bit.
And he was an older man.
He was jogging, you know.
I took a photo as he
was running by me.
And then, he stops, and
we look at the photo.
And he says, wow, that's great.
And I go, all right.
There you go.
He says, take another one.
That happened for
all four miles.
[LAUGHTER]
And the only way I could
think of to be a good guest
was to go with it.
So I started
pretending like this
was a photo shoot in my head.
I'm like, I can't
be embarrassed.
There's Japanese men in
full grown suits running
so they can be early to a bus.
Not on time, but early.
That's amazing.
I can totally run down,
and lay on the ground,
and climb up trees in
a button up shirt just
to make this guy
happy to make it seem
like I'm being a good guess.
And I did that.
And I laid down, and as
he ran upstairs in almost
like a Rocky Balboa fashion,
I took photos of him
from trees, from the
ground, and I probably
have around 150 photos over
the course of four miles.
And when we got back, he was
bragging to a translator.
And he was like, oh, he's so
[INAUDIBLE], like energetic.
He's like, were you
in the military?
No.
I was never in the military.
I just had no idea what
else to do because you
kept asking me to take photos.
JASON ANDREAS: Sounds
like you were, maybe,
on a hidden camera Japanese
game show, in my opinion.
[LAUGHTER]
I want to check the internet.
You might be out
there somewhere.
[LAUGHTER]
BRENDON EDWARDS: I'll put
that in your guys' boat.
You are Google.
I figure if anyone's
gonna find it--
JASON ANDREAS: I'll do
some research after this.
BRENDON EDWARDS: Yeah.
JASON ANDREAS: I can,
maybe, find some clips.
BRENDON EDWARDS:
But anyway, that's
my initial impression of being
a host and being a guest.
And I came back to the
US with a perspective
on a few different cultures
and how they react.
And I think it's
really interesting now
that I have that perspective.
I deal with hundreds
of people a day
coming in, sitting down, eating.
Sometimes they don't
like what they eat.
So how do you do that?
How do you compensate?
How do you work with
them, as a host?
And my usual thing is I want to
be as good of a host as I can.
So I translate that, and
I say, you don't like.
I'll get you something else.
I won't charge you for that.
I'll get you dessert.
I will buy you a
drink because if it
was someone in your
house, what would you do?
And then, also comes the duality
of how are they a good guest?
At Gold Cash Gold,
this is fairly telling,
but I'm going to tell it anyway.
I had a group of, like,
20-year-old girls come in.
It was 10 of them
on a Friday night.
8 o'clock.
And they all came in.
They seemed like they
were good guests.
Everything was fine.
They all ordered sandwiches.
Burgers and chicken sandwiches.
Every single one of them
got it and sent it back
to the kitchen.
I was like, aw
man, what's wrong?
All of a sudden, I
see all these servers
coming back to the kitchen.
This is a reverse flow.
I'm nervous, at this moment.
They didn't not like them.
They just wanted
them cut in half.
All 10 of them.
[LAUGHTER]
Now on a Friday
night, as a chef,
I am a composed chef,
most of the time.
But in certain moments, it's
hard to hold your composure.
I cut all of those sandwiches
in half with a cleaver
because I was like I
have more food coming out
and more food coming this way.
This feels not good.
And I think this was
the question that I've
started to push upon
myself, and diners,
and also see how America
is actually relating to it
in terms of how do we walk in.
And how do we be a guest?
How do I be a better host?
And I think America's kind of
translating that and pushing it
forward.
We're creating our own identity.
Cultures came in and changed
the way we work with food.
And they came in, usually
coming from a lesser,
into what America is,
which is an abundance.
And that's actually a really
beautiful thing about America.
Our quality started to diminish.
If you look at Folgers and
the major coffee companies
in World War II, they
actually changed their beans
from Arabica to the
lesser bean, which I can't
remember the name of right now.
But they changed their beans.
And if you actually
check out their sales,
their sales
actually-- by person--
less people start
drinking coffee
because they started caring
less about the quality of what
they're doing.
And therefore, their
product suffered.
That being said, they're
still a major preparer
of coffee goods
and all that jazz.
You can still buy them in
every store that you can find.
But I don't want to
deal with volume.
I want to deal with quality
because my thought is
that I want to be a host.
I want to be your person for
the moment where you walk in,
and you feel good about
the day that you came.
Your first date.
Your second date.
Your anniversary.
You're meeting with friends.
And that's what I do
on a regular basis.
And you can see that is changing
with Selden Standard that
opened up in Detroit, which,
hopefully, you've gone there,
or Chartreuse, or Mabel Gray,
and numerous other chefs.
Rose's Fine Foods.
They all fit their
own way of hosting.
And they're all trying to do
better in their communities
and for you, as guests,
when you go there.
And it's my goal to
keep pushing that.
And I think, also, it's my goal
to start teaching guests how
to be guests too because I
think that's an important part.
It's a relationship when
you walk into a restaurant.
And it's not always an easy one.
Often, it's tumultuous.
And therein lies my
general thoughts.
I stopped looking at
my notes awhile ago.
How are we looking on time?
JASON ANDREAS: We're good.
I was going to ask a question
about that last point
that you made in
terms of expectations
around hosts and guests, right.
So I feel like Detroit
is carving out, kind of,
a unique ecosystem.
And you've worked a lot
in Chicago, as well.
Both typical standard,
Midwest, American cities
where you've got the
Midwest hospitality overall.
Have you spent time
on either coast?
New York, Boston,
D.C, or west coast?
San Francisco?
L.A?
And how does the expectation
of the guest host
differ from the core
Midwest type ecosystem
to one of the coasts
where things are maybe
a little bit more rigid
on the east coast or maybe
a little bit more laid
back on the west coast?
BRENDON EDWARDS: Yeah.
Once again, if you
go to Europe, you'll
see their styles of hospitality.
Their general food, stuff
they serve, all changes.
And I think I see four
distinct regions--
and there probably
is a lot more--
but you see the east coast,
the west coast, the Midwest,
and then the south.
My dad's actually
from South Carolina.
So I spent a decent amount
of time in the south.
My sister lives in L.A.
So I got to actually work.
I spent two months out there.
And then, I just
staged at restaurants.
So I was a babysitter to
my niece for a while, which
was really great.
And then, I would
just, occasionally,
relieve myself of them having
to think about me because I
thought I was a burden.
So I'd just go and work at,
like, Animal and whatnot,
which are just restaurants
I really wanted to go to.
And I think there's a lot more
expectations on the east coast,
from my understanding from
cooks I've worked with.
As all industries
are, we're kind of
like this really small
community that you
think is really
big because there's
thousands and thousands and
thousands of restaurants
across the US.
But there's not many
cities in the US
that I don't know
a cook or a chef
because we've all,
kind of, gone around.
it's the beauty to cooking.
I can go anywhere, and cook
somewhere, and learn something,
and a lot of cooks do that.
My perspective on L.A, which
isn't quite west coast--
meaning it's a little
different from Portland to L.A,
and then going down to San Diego
but very specifically on L.A--
I feel like it was a
type of hospitality where
the host isn't as important
as the other guests, not even
on an equal playing field.
But a lot of places were a place
where you'd go more to be seen
and to eat and drink
the things that
were popular to eat and drink.
I think L.A is changing
though, since I've been.
The Midwest-- I even
feel like Chicago,
even though it has a
Midwest personality--
there's still a lot of
east coast drive behind it
because New York, Austin,
those sort of places,
you walk into the kitchens,
they're really small.
At Longman & Eagle, the
area that I prepped,
I couldn't even stand up.
I'm six foot tall.
So I actually, kind
of, developed a stance.
I didn't bend my knees.
I just, sort of,
spread my feet out.
And then, all the cooks around
me also did that because if you
were above 5'10, you'd probably
hit your head on a pipe
downstairs.
A couple of people actually
knocked themselves out in rush.
But yeah, I feel
like the east coast
is a little bit more driven,
a little bit more competitive.
The Midwest tends to
be a little bit more--
and very specifically, Detroit--
tends to be more
community driven.
JASON ANDREAS: Yeah, for sure.
BRENDON EDWARDS:
You can definitely
see that I had friends
that opened up Grey Ghost.
You guys talked to John.
JASON ANDREAS: Yeah.
John was in a couple weeks ago.
BRENDON EDWARDS: Yeah.
And he called me up
maybe a week ago now.
And he just had questions for
me of purveyors, who to ask.
And in general chef culture, you
don't give away your secrets.
But in Detroit,
it's like, oh, where
do you find some odd thing
that you normally can't find,
such as caul fat,
or tonka beans,
or just some culinary oddity
that you don't normally see?
And it's hard to find.
You won't find it
in a grocery store.
Where can I get this?
JASON ANDREAS: Sure.
BRENDON EDWARDS: And
you share those things.
We share each other's kitchens.
Opening up Standby,
I had Chef Joe,
who is part of Grey
Ghost working at Standby.
I had Kate Williams
in my kitchen.
I had Brian Wong from
Peterborough in my kitchen.
And they were all
technically working
at an hourly wage for me.
Most chefs wouldn't
allow other chefs
to just do that so freely.
JASON ANDREAS: We had Chef
James Rigato in from Mabel Gray
a couple weeks ago.
And you know, he
does a lot of stuff
at Mabel Gray where he
brings in his favorite chefs.
He's like, I like this
person's restaurant.
I'm going to have them come
in and guest chef for a couple
days.
And you don't hear about that
too often outside of Detroit.
I feel like that's fairly
unique to this type of community
atmosphere.
It does happen, obviously.
But it's a lot more
official than other places
where something
like Next Chicago
brings in a guest chef for
a three month rotation.
Whereas, this is maybe
one night you go cook
at Mabel Gray for a few hours.
And it's kind of not
really heavily publicized.
It's more just, hey,
let's create a community
in this Detroit ecosystem.
Have a little fun
with it more than
being something a little
more rigid and official.
BRENDON EDWARDS: Yeah.
And I think of all things
that Detroit has going for it,
I did my first pop
up here in 2009.
It's called The Breakfast Club.
It started at midnight
in Rush Park, Detroit.
And it ended at 5:00 AM.
I had Andy Holiday from
Selden as, sort of,
my stand in sous chef.
Not that he was my sous chef,
but I made all this food,
and then he was helping
me plate everything.
We had 400 people walk in the
door starting at midnight.
And it was just this thing
that had been bubbling.
And I feel like if
anything Detroit has,
it's starting this birthplace
of this cooperative nature
in the culinary industry.
And I think there's lots
of reasons for that,
but I think that that's one
of the most beautiful things
that's always drawn
me back to Detroit.
I mean, I've left and
come back at least
half a dozen times now.
And every time-- actually,
I grew up with James Rigato.
So we both went to
Howell High School.
We were in the same art class.
So small world.
JASON ANDREAS: You
may want to check out
the talk he did with us.
He wasn't very kind
to the city of Howell.
So we had to put a little
disclaimer on there.
[LAUGHTER]
He didn't mention
you in particular.
But Howell, in
general, he said he
was happy to get
away from Howell
and spend more time
traveling, as well.
So check it out next
time you get a chance.
BRENDON EDWARDS: Yeah.
JASON ANDREAS: I was
going to ask you too.
And then, if anyone
else has any questions,
feel free to raise your hand.
We'll get you a microphone.
We asked this question
of all of our chefs.
And we've gotten a lot of, I
guess, semi mixed responses
but all very similar.
So obviously, you're
here at Google.
We talk about expectations of
hosts and chefs at restaurants.
And then, you play
the technology layer
on top of that, right.
So you've got things
these days like Yelp
where the technology of Yelp
and the immediacy of information
and feedback has really changed
expectations from, both,
the host perspective in terms of
how they have to host somebody
who can put a bad
review out, literally,
in real time if their
10 sandwiches are cut
in half in the right way versus
guests who now have higher
expectations because
of what they've read
from other folks who
have been patrons
of the restaurant
and things like that.
How do you view the
merge of technology
and this kind of
host guest ecosystem
that you've been chatting about.
BRENDON EDWARDS: I
think there's a lot
to be said about the
immediacy of being
able to review and criticize.
I usually try and
spend a decent amount
of time in the dining room
just talking to guests
and seeing how
they are because I
think that's one of those
things that's important.
You do need to keep that
door open to say like, hey, I
don't like this
or, hey, this isn't
what I expected because my job
and our job in the hospitality
industry is figuring out what
you want as best as we can.
But we have moments
to figure that out,
and then to do it in such a
way that you don't notice it
because my thought
of hospitality
oftentimes is kind of magical.
You walk into a restaurant.
You get your piece of
paper set before you.
If you go to Moto, which
isn't open anymore,
you could have actually
eaten it, as well.
[LAUGHING]
But then, you just point
to something on the menu,
and you say I want that.
And magically, it comes out.
Hopefully, the way
you expect or better.
So I'd actually spend
time with people.
I think that's something
that we're lacking.
And I think, once
again, in the reverse,
people aren't open to
actually right then
and there saying
like, hey, actually,
this drink is too bitter.
It's like, oh, well you
chose a vieux carre.
It's kind of a bitter drink.
Or you don't like campari,
probably don't get a negroni.
And that discussion needs
to actually be happening.
Just like any good
relationship, whether it's
with your mom and
dad, your siblings,
or a significant other,
you need to be talking.
And I think Yelp kind of
masks that, more or less.
It's the ability to kind
of hide behind something
without actually engaging
in a real conversation.
That being said, I've
read Yelp reviews
on the food I've done,
the places I've worked,
and I've been very
sympathetic to them, as well.
Or maybe a better term would
be empathetic because knowing
that there are
times where we fail.
And I feel bad that we fail
as a general community.
And that's totally
your right to do that.
If you sit down--
I know I did this once at a
California Pizza Kitchen--
I sat down, and it became
almost a game to me
to see how long it was going
to be before someone actually
acknowledged me.
And initially it was
like, oh, five minutes.
I mean, it's kind of long.
Seven.
10.
Now this is fun.
Like, I think I need to get
a free meal out of this.
Like, it took 22 minutes
when I went there.
[LAUGHTER]
And I watched
servers and things.
And that's not right.
There is a thing of you
can't actually be wrong.
And you do deserve a voice.
But there should be
a discussion too.
JASON ANDREAS: Yep.
BRENDON EDWARDS:
So when I did that
at California Pizza Kitchen,
I didn't write a Yelp review.
But I did mention it to the
manager and say, like, hey,
this wasn't quite right.
I do do this for
a living, as well.
But you should
probably watch that.
JASON ANDREAS: Yeah.
BRENDON EDWARDS: You know?
JASON ANDREAS: Well I think the
consensus has been conversation
and two way feedback is good.
But hiding behind technology
and having the courage
to Yelp it out to
all of your friends
as you're sitting there,
but not the courage
to say something to
the waiter or waitress,
or to ask to speak with the
chef is not quite the right way
to go about it.
So I think we've got a
long way to go with that.
But I think it
certainly provides
some valuable feedback,
in some cases,
is the consensus we've
heard around the block.
BRENDON EDWARDS: I think--
JASON ANDREAS: Oh, I'm sorry.
Go ahead.
BRENDON EDWARDS: One
other note on that.
JASON ANDREAS: Yeah, sure.
BRENDON EDWARDS:
Appropriate ways
to handle those situations,
if it doesn't get solved
at the establishment with
you talking to someone
or you don't feel comfortable
saying it, send an email,
as in a nonpublic forum.
And if they still are ignoring
you, please, post the Yelp.
[LAUGHTER]
Because I know even on things--
and proper criticism, not
like I didn't like it.
I had someone actually
tell me that they
didn't like something,
and what they had ordered
was mushroom based.
And they said, I don't like it.
I'm like, oh, what's wrong?
Well they didn't tell me
this until after they left,
by the way.
So they said, I didn't like it.
I said, what's wrong?
It was like, well, I ate
it, and it just wasn't good.
I don't understand
what you mean.
Can you explain, like, how do
I make this better for you?
And they said, I
don't like mushrooms.
[LAUGHTER]
And I just, kind of, was like,
I don't know how to fix that.
[LAUGHTER]
I mean, that's like
I would like the--
JASON ANDREAS: It's a tough one.
BRENDON EDWARDS: I would
like the filet mignon,
but I don't like beef.
Is it all right?
No, you're not gonna like it.
So there needs to be criticism
with words and an explanation
of this was too salty
or this was, you know,
certain things that
we do mess up on.
It's a hard skill
to understand how
to actually season something
with salt properly every time,
especially when I
have fish coming
in from two different oceans
that has a different salinity
content that you have to season
a halibut different than you
season a skate wing different
than you season a local salmon
that's farm raised or
something like that.
So there's things like that
that are really difficult.
And it's hard for
a cook to learn,
and you should
mention that, and be
specific about your complaints.
JASON ANDREAS: I think
the proper way to salt
is like this, right?
Like the salt guy?
BRENDON EDWARDS: You're right.
Yeah.
JASON ANDREAS: Just let it
roll down your arm and all
over the fish.
So as long as you do it that
way, it usually comes out well.
BRENDON EDWARDS: Yeah.
JASON ANDREAS: Any questions?
You guys have anything else?
If not, I've got one more
before we wrap things up.
BRENDON EDWARDS: I tell all
my cooks I like questions.
JASON ANDREAS: Usually a good
thing in the kitchen, right?
BRENDON EDWARDS: Yeah.
JASON ANDREAS: Let
me ask you just
as we wrap things your thoughts
on where Detroit goes next.
Detroit is, kind
of, this cool up
and coming city
that's experiencing
this really cool
renaissance in music,
and art, and all these
different things.
And food is a huge
staple of that.
You're, obviously,
a part of that.
It's come a long way
in the past few years.
What do you see being the
next one or two big things?
Or what do the
next few years look
like in the city of Detroit
to carve out its niche
in the national scene?
BRENDON EDWARDS: I think Detroit
definitely has the ability
to do things that other
major cities haven't.
It has the ability to
hold true to its nature.
And hopefully with the
investments and everything
that goes into it, that
thought of gentrification
and whatnot of pushing the city
of what it was out, hopefully,
it holds together.
I know my aggravations
with other major cities
like downtown Chicago,
only the people
that could afford to be downtown
ended up being downtown.
And then, downtown
wasn't as great.
I think and I hope
that Detroit has
a possibility of doing
that, of being something
more community based, more based
on the relationships of all
the people that
have already created
what is good in Detroit.
And I mean, I definitely
see a continuing surge
in residential
population and everything
else that's going to
keep driving the city
to do more things
and be more creative.
A lot of people that I've
talked to, creatives especially,
are coming to Detroit because
of those opportunities.
And if the people who are
most relevant in the control
of Detroit pay
attention to that,
then I think that's
going to be one
of the most wonderful
changes that you'll
see in Detroit in
the next five years
is the creativity, and
the push, and the drive
to make a city that is, kind
of, unlike most cities around.
And my only big
hope that I haven't
seen any real promise of it
is more public transportation.
[LAUGHTER]
JASON ANDREAS:
They're working on it.
The M1, right?
Is that what it's
called, the M1 rail line?
BRENDON EDWARDS: It's a start.
AUDIENCE: The Q line.
JASON ANDREAS: The Q line.
BRENDON EDWARDS: Q line.
JASON ANDREAS:
Very well, Brandon.
You Well thank you very much
for all of your insight.
I like the idea of community.
It's huge, obviously, in
the Midwest in Detroit.
And for a lot of
us, nothing promotes
community quite like food does.
So thank you for
the part that you've
played in all of the
restaurants around Detroit.
Thank you for coming in.
We'll make sure, based on
all of your advice, that we
try to strive to be
better guests in all
of the restaurants we attend.
I don't think anyone
owns a restaurant here.
So we can't really
host that well.
You can host at home, I suppose.
But be a good host at home.
And we'll all try
and be the best guest
that we possibly can.
So thank you, once again, to
Chef Edwards for coming in.
Big, quick round of applause.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]